bonsoir mardi 8 juin bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres
c'est demain mercredi que l'étape 3 du
déconfinement sera déclenchée avec
notamment le passage du couvre-feu à 23
heures
reportage dans deux salles de sport qui
se préparent pour leur première
réouverture depuis l'automne invite
également cliquer ordinariat ans à la
tête du restaurant la fontaine à
montigny le bretonneux pour parler de
l'accueil des clients de nouveau
autorisée en intérieur elle agit pour
lutter contre l'exclusion dans les
quartiers prioritaires la conduction de
positif planète pour ce faire la
création d'entreprises l'association
interne et d'accompagner depuis sa
fondation deux millions de bénéficiaires
dans le monde attrape une antenne locale
est implanté et rayonne dans tout le sud
yvelines
et puis aux mureaux un magasin a fait le
pari du rétro cette boutique éphémère
consacrés aux disques et vinyle sera
ouverte pendant six mois le temps de
constater si les adeptes du vintage sont
au rendez vous au moment où le métier de
disquaires est en voie de disparition et
à la proche des élections
départementales portraits croisés dans
ce journal dans le canton de
bonnières-sur-seine deux candidats
connus de la sphère politique et sociale
sont en lice d'un côté l'homme de droite
patrick stefanini ancien préfet ancien
conseiller d'état et de l'autre pierre
ac razouqi fils de l'ancien secrétaire
général de la cgt c'est à suivre dans
cette édition
le déconfinement entre donc dans une
phase supplémentaires dès mercredi dès
demain avec une levée des restrictions
un supplémentaire l'essentiel à retenir
qui s'affiche avec le passage du
couvre-feu de 21h à 23h et notamment
vous le voyez la réouverture des bars et
restaurants en intérieur depuis le 19
mai ce sont les terrasses qui avait pu
accueillir à nouveau les clients
krikor dinars y en est avec tom en
visioconférence bonsoir vous êtes le
dirigeant du restaurant el la fontaine
c'est à montigny le bretonneux juste
avant de vous poser des questions vous
l'avez vu aussi sur l'animation
précédentes les salles de sport aussi
vont pouvoir rouvrir à partir de demain
et pour la première fois depuis
l'automne elle les établissements se
prépare donc à un jour de la réouverture
il le veut ils vont mettre en place ils
sont obligés de mettre en place un
protocole sanitaires strictes et des
jauges aussi un qui sont revus à la
baisse
exemple dans deux établissements à
montigny le bretonneux et du en cours
avec michael et demi d'euros elle compte
les heures après huit mois de cours à
distance la coach céline pourra recevoir
à nouveau des sportifs dans sa salle de
montigny le bretonneux à partir de ce
mercredi 9 juin
je vais avoir peut-être c'est pas un
cours zoom par jour versus 5 à 6 heures
par jour et puis je re bascule de
l'autre côté au jour et cinq à six
heures de cours ici dans cette salle qui
a besoin de ressentir à nouveau à la
soeur forcément parce que nous on
transpire pas beaucoup en yoga et
pilates
mais les bonnes ondes ce retour dans
cette salle de 80 mètres carrés sera
accompagné d'un protocole sanitaire
je ne mettrai jamais plus de cinq
personnes
parce que je veux que chacun se sente en
sécurité je déjà arrêterait tous les
cours cinq minutes vraiment avant la fin
pour que chacun ait le temps de
désinfecter à la lotion hydroalcoolique
son espace
même s'il vient avec son tapis et qu'ils
aient le temps de sortir et que le
groupe suivant et le temps de rentrer
sans que ça se croisent à l'intérieur du
studio dans cette salle de sport à
guyancourt les gérants sont également
prêts à accueillir leurs mille adhérents
pour cela un disque
et yves stricte semblable au premier
déconfinement sera également mis en
place le gel à disposition de l'un
tendue à l'entrée du club désinfecter
son matériel avant et après
l'utilisation les serviettes lady
sensation de 10 mètres carrés par
adhérent il va y avoir une chose de 50 %
d'adhérents donc pour nous pour nous ce
sera à peu près 70 personnes en même
temps
ben club les douches individuelles donc
ils vont être condamnés une sur deux les
cases et de la même façon la principale
nouveauté sera la mise en place d'un qr
code a flashé à son arrivée dans la
salle pour accéder à un cahier de rappel
numérique
il suffit de télécharger l'application
anti covin signal et 2
cliquez sur le scan qr code sur son
téléphone et il suffira juste de se
caler ce petit qr codes là en 30
secondes et ça montrera son passage dans
la salle à telle heure quel jour et
celle de sport espère maintenant que ce
dispositif permettra de relancer la
machine et surtout inciter les sportifs
à s'inscrire à la rentrée prochaine un
moment clé pour le secteur et je vous le
disais tout à l'heure en plus de la
réouverture des salles de sport d'autres
levée de restrictions à partir de demain
mercredi
couvre-feu à 23h et ouverture des salons
fort d'exposition avec jauge fin du
télétravail systématique et donc la
réouverture en intérieur des bars et
restaurants qui accueillait pour ceux
qui avaient une terrasse et des clients
depuis le 19 mai krikor dynario vous
êtes toujours avec nous vous êtes le
dirigeant du restaurant la fontaine
c'est à montigny le bretonneux
quel est votre état d'esprit à aj - 1 de
cette nouvelle levée de restrictions
eh bien nous sommes très heureux un peu
fébrile nous sommes tous sur la brèche
depuis déjà plusieurs jours pour
préparer la réouverture de la salle à
l'intérieur que je peux pour l'instant
le juge a été un coup compromise par la
météo qui nous a joué des tours et donc
fébrile et coraux de revoir nos clients
alors plusieurs mesures qui vous
concerne la principale bien sûr c'est
cette possibilité d'accueillir de
nouveau des clients en salle avec une
jauge de 50% en intérieur six personnes
maximum par table
tout est prêt pour accueillir vos
clients bien sûr tout est prêt depuis
déjà un petit moment on peut on a la
chance à la fontaine d'avoir beaucoup de
place donc la distanciation à
l'intérieur et la jauge à 50% ne va pas
être trop problématique de et avec la
terrasse qui complète la météo qui est
bien meilleure maintenant la thiérache
qui pourrait accueillir beaucoup de
monde donc je pense que tout est prêt
pour une réouverture heureuse pour nos
clients je demandais juste à l'équipe
technique d'augmenter un petit peu le
sens de ce qu on vous entend assez mal
en plateau creek ordinariat du coup je
n'ai pas compris si vous avez
réorganiser est-ce que ça a été
difficile de réorganiser l'intérieur
pour pouvoir justement
accueillir cette jauge de 50% à
l'intérieur où finalement ça a été assez
simple à mettre en place
on ne critique pas vraiment puisque nous
avons déjà l'expérience des périodes
passées l'année dernière donc on a déjà
fait ça l'été dernier l'automne dernier
donc n'a pas été très difficile pour
nous mais bon il ya d'autres
établissements qui sont plus petits qui
ont un petit peu plus de difficultés
parce que c'est difficile pour eux de
division 2 une salle qui est déjà pas
très grande mais bon pour nous ça n'a
pas posé trop de problèmes et je pense
que honda répandre sans probables
difficultés le 30 juin avec une nouvelle
levée des restrictions qui est prévue le
30 juin du coup avec cette
réorganisation ces jo jo 50% vous serez
à combien de couverts possible dans
votre salle dans la salle on pourra
accueillir facilement 50 personnes 50
personnes pour votre salle donc votre
restaurant à montigny le bretonneux
on parlait aussi de la mise en place de
ces protocoles je le disais les jauges
de 50% 6 personnes par table et il
parlait on en parlait aussi dans dans
les différents protocoles la mise en
place d'un qr codes ou d'un cahier de
rappel pour pouvoir rappeler facilement
un client qui serait déceler positif aux
colis de 19 quelques jours plus tard le
ministre de la santé olivier derand a
annoncé finalement que ces cahiers de
rappel ne serait pas obligatoire mais
vivement recommandée est ce que vous
avez décidé vous d'en mettre en place au
restaurant la fontaine
bien sûr des salles de sport de vote
avant moi la mettre à disposition le
tuèrent pub pour les personnes qui
peuvent utiliser chez nous nous avons le
cahier d'appel physique
nous avons toutes les coordonnées de nos
clients avec la table à laquelle ils ont
déjeuné
c'est à dire restaurant et le moment où
ils sont venus nature alors l'autre
mesure bien sûr c'est le passage du
couvre feu de 21 heures à 23 heures avec
des services dont qui vont pouvoir être
étendue ça ça va forcément changer la
donne pas évidemment là pour l'instant
c'est un petit tour de chauffe on met à
band 3 heures c'est pour nous c'est
presque un retour à la normale bien sûr
avec aussi une capacité en terrasse qui
va passer à 100% la jauge était à 50%
depuis le
mais le temps n'a pas forcément été au
rendez vous même si maintenant la météo
s'est améliorée écrit cordina riant est
ce que les les clients malgré on va dire
le temps maussade ont quand même été au
rendez vous le 19 mai ce que vous avez
pu retravailler relancer votre activité
à nouveau non pas vraiment on a eu on a
fait une petite tentative ou deux mais
l'année tournoi vraiment beaucoup trop
contrarié donc on a préféré juste après
la fête des mères arrêter complètement
pour attendre sagement une bonne météo
et surtout beau 9 juin qui est attendu
avec une très grande impatience le monde
de la restauration a notamment est
accompagné par l'état pour faire face à
cette période fonds de solidarité
chômage partiel prêts garantis par par
l'état vous avez eu justement vous
recours aux prêts garantis par l'état à
hauteur de 137 1000 euros vous étiez
venu en parler ici même en plateau vous
commencerez vous l'aviez indiqué en
février à rembourser à partir de l'année
prochaine ce prêt garanti par l'état
certains restaurateurs malgré ces aides
se disent tout de même inquiet puisque
depuis le 1er juin à ces aides ont
progressivement baissé ce jusqu'en
septembre avec notamment une partie du
chômage partiel inquiète désormais à la
charge des employeurs
est ce que vous êtes de nature inquiète
est ce que vous êtes inquiet ou plutôt
optimiste pour la suite je suis plutôt
qui vit c'est une question de nature
mais bon on est quand même un petit peu
dans l'expectative on se demande comment
aurait on gêne aux clients qui sont très
demandeurs certes mais lorsqu'on va être
entre guillemets des branches et des
aides de l'état progressivement
il va falloir être prêt pour faire face
notamment le chômage partiel qui va
diminuer fortement
et puis un autre sujet qu'il faudra
aborder rapidement c'est le manque de
personnel dans la profession comment
faire revenir dans notre métier des
personnes qui ont quitté ce métier c'est
difficile de les faire revenir mais ça
c'est un autre sujet maintenant qui est
sur la table
ah oui ça sujet sérieux qui va l'être de
plus en plus isolé chaque sim actives
yens
merci creek ordinariat d'avoir est avec
nous
merci et je le rappelle vous êtes le
dirigeant du restaurant la fontaine il
est situé à montigny le bretonneux le
point à présent sur la vaccination dans
les yvelines ouverte depuis une semaine
à tous les plus de 18 ans sans critères
de santé au 6 juin 541 1518 personnes
avaient été pris mot vacciner dans les
yvelines soit 53 milles en plus sur une
semaine deux cent trente huit mille
personnes sont complètement vaccinés sur
le territoire et blinois j'ajoute que la
vaccination des 12-18 ans débutera elle
à partir du 15 juin à rambouillet
d'ailleurs la municipalité en
collaboration avec l'hôpital et
professionnels de santé de la ville et
la rs a ouvert depuis hier un maxi drive
elle se il sera ce maxi drive en place à
partir donc il était il est en place à
partir de lundi pardon depuis lundi et
il sera en place jusqu'à vendredi à
l'hippodrome de rambouillet le principe
vous recevez directement votre injection
à bord de votre véhicule avant de
stationner dans une aire dédiée pendant
15 minutes pour surveiller d'éventuels
effets secondaires est la vaccination
sur place est ouverte uniquement sur
rendez vous et il faut prendre rendez
vous sur le site d'octo lille.fr
l'objectif est de 2700 personnes
vaccinées d'ici vendredi à rambouillet
se lancer dans la création d'entreprise
une aventure qui peut faire peur
l'association ou positif planète est
lancé il ya 20 ans est justement les
porteurs de projets essentiellement dans
les quartiers populaires une conviction
l'entrepreneuriat pour lutter contre
l'exclusion exemple la trappe avec
bérengère bourgoin et astrid bergère
mariam couture est une jeune entreprise
créée à trappes
il y a un an et demi ces gérants ne
connaissait pas le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat grâce à l'association
de positif planète qui accompagnent des
porteurs de projets des les quartiers
populaires ils ont réussi à se lancer
c'est positif planète francescas et
occupait vraiment de nous assister à
travers quatre entretiens et on lui
apporter toutes les informations par
rapport aux prix comme envoyer les prix
des rideaux comme envoyer les prix des
tickets de ty et des coussins et là on a
réussi à monter un business plan solide
et on a réussi à acquérir grâce grâce à
ce business plan
l'activité a commencé on a réussi à
acquérir un atelier grâce à eux leur
activité repose principalement sur la
création de salon orientaux et deux
coups simples un an et demi après la
création de l'entreprise
ils sont satisfaits on s'est vraiment
une fierté parce que ça s'est fait à
trappes et il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
nous ont vus évoluer qui nous ont vus
transporté ddd du tissu dans notre
voiture familiale et on a commencé
vraiment bas de l'échelle et quand ils
voient ça ils se disent ah ouais c'est
possible on essaie peut-être on peut on
peut le faire chaque semaine leur
conseillère vient les voir pour répondre
à leurs interrogations et les aider en
2020 une antenne yvelinoise de
l'association a fait plus de 2 100
accompagnement et a permis la création
de 50 et une entreprise l'objectif de
positif planète france c'est de redonner
confiance à toutes les personnes qui
souhaitent développer des initiatives
économiques et ce quelle que soit leur
parcours de vie et leur projet et c'est
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui et notamment
sur sur le département des yvelines avec
notre quatre lieux de permanence
actuelle donc sur trappe mantes-la-jolie
et mentale ville les mureaux et boissy
et l'association aide les porteurs de
projets sur l'ensemble de la création de
l'entreprise
si les porteurs de projets
certaines techniques notamment sur le
marketing sur le la stratégie digitale
sur voilà sur pas mal de thématiques le
choix notamment du statut juridique et
ça s'est fait autant en entretien
individuel que en action collective
quatre personnes travaillent sur
l'antenne des yvelines l'association est
financée principalement par des fonds
publics comme le fonds social européen
et le département du 28 juin au 3
juillet se déroulera une nouvelle
édition des rendez vous de la retraite
une semaine à destination de tous les
actifs de tout âge pour faire le point
sur leur situation personnelle cet
événement national se déclinera aussi au
niveau de l'île de france où il est
d'ores et déjà possible de prendre
rendez-vous 5000 entretien vous seront
proposées dans la région
ils peuvent se faire soit par téléphone
soit en rendez vous en présentiel dans
l'un des points d'information retrait du
département à guyancourt montigny le
bretonneux et poissy au chapitre
politique les élections départementales
et régionales au programme les 20 et 27
juin prochains pour le scrutin des
départementales dans le canton de
bonnières-sur-seine quatre binômes sont
en lice dans le nord des yvelines une
élection avec en toile de fond un duel
entre deux noms connus dans la sphère
politique et sociale française est d'un
côté le candidat de l'union de la droite
et du centre patrick stefanini et de
l'autre pierre krasucki qui représente
le parti communiste français il est le
fils d'henri krasucki secrétaire général
de la cgt entre 1982 et 1992 pour très
croisée signée nicolas landry il a mené
la victoire de jacques chirac pour la
présidentielle de 1995 et celle de
valérie pécresse pour les régionales de
on le surnomme du coup le faiseur de roi
aujourd'hui patrick stefanini et
candidat au départemental dans les
yvelines
il est en binôme avec josette gens dans
le canton de bonnières-sur-seine 50 ans
typiquement rural avec beaucoup de
petites communes des communes qui ont
moins de 1000 habitants
nous sommes dans un canton où il faut
beaucoup travailler sur les questions de
mobilité gestion des collèges
problématique des transports questions
de sécurité en zone rurale différents
points du programme du candidat du
groupe ensemble pour les yvelines
diplômé de l'ena en 1979 patrick
stefanini a occupé plusieurs postes dans
la haute fonction publique
il a aussi été préfet dans plusieurs
départements
aujourd'hui il mène sa campagne
notamment auprès des maires du canton
merci beaucoup monsieur le maire au
revoir comme préfet j'ai servi notamment
à clermont ferrand dans le département
du puy-de-dôme
j'ai servi à bordeaux dans le
département de la gironde
j'ai l'habitude de la relation avec les
maires et moi je mettrai au service de
notre binôme et à partir de là au
service de l'ensemble des maires et donc
de tous les habitants du canton
je mettrai mon expérience de l'état et
mon expérience de la région puisque j'ai
dirigé pendant plus d'un an les services
de la région du côté de
bonnières-sur-seine la gauche avec
notamment le parti communiste français
aura un binôme avec héloïse venancio et
pierre krasucki ce dernier est le fils
d'henri krasucki secrétaire général de
la cgt de 1982 à 1992 il a aussi été
membre de la résistance pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale est envoyé en
camp de déportation vers le bus de
beethoven là vous voyez là sur la halle
et on vous dit disque bah c'est ce qu'il
avait dans sa salle à manger
il était fou amoureux il adorait
beethoven à noël en 43 et s'est mis à
siffler la septième symphonie de
beethoven qui leur faisait tenir parce
que psychologiquement fallait tenir
pierre krasucki conserve aujourd'hui
tous les rites elle de l'engagement
politique de son père la volonté de
faire quelque chose pour défendre les
gens assad à des injustices comme elles
se produisent à travers les politiques
mises en place depuis maintenant par
manet panda 2 pendant la décennie
j'ai milité pendant près de 40 ans dans
mon entreprise et j'assume toutes les
responsabilités de secrétaire de 110 cas
en passant par délégué syndical élu
c'est l'élu c'est en posant penser au
chs s est finie délégation du personnel
toujours militant de la cgt pour les
retraités reste engagé au parti
communiste français
c'est sous cette couleur qu'il souhaite
proposer une alternance autour d'une
union de la gauche aux élections
départementales avec plusieurs
propositions notamment autour de
l'environnement la santé la solidarité
envers les personnes âgées mais aussi la
jeunesse il ya actuellement une
plateforme d'e
monopoly si je puis dire le système
scolaire c'est celui des joies et ses
midis bomba et c'est une gestion privée
or nous priver on n'en veut pas on veut
une gestion publique
si son engagement et plus syndical
pierre krasucki à une expérience des
campagnes électorales
il a notamment était déjà candidat pour
une élection cantonale et suppléant lors
des élections législatives de 2012
le rétro est il définitivement de retour
une boutique éphémère en tout cas fait
le pari du vintage elle vend 10 kevin
hill aux mureaux un test de six mois
portés par la ressourcerie des devis le
reportage de bixente maria santisteva
dvd disques vinyles la boutique mur au
disque offre à ses clients un flash back
à travers les décennies voire des
siècles
quand vous venez dans notre boutique
vous fait effectivement un retour en
arrière mais vous avez je dirais le
sentiment de trouver des choses qui
satisfont tout le monde jeunes moins
jeunes
ancien mais toujours avec la même fibre
de trouver je dirais une petite pépite
de beethoven à elvis presley en passant
par les classiques de la chanson
française
chacun peut y trouver son compte avec
même certaines pièces plus original
exemple nous avons un empire qui est le
roi de la flûte de pan
donc il faut aimer mes dédicaces et
chose quand même à peu près unique
atahualpa yupanqui qui est très connu
aussi sur la musique des andes
en tout ce sont 1600 vinyles et autres
produits reçus pour la plupart de la
ressourcerie des quevilly ce chantier
d'insertion qui récupère du matériel
ancien et porteur du projet mur au
disque la ressourcerie on reçoit
beaucoup de matériel dvd vinyles et on a
pensé que ça pouvait être l'occasion de
créer un emploi est aussi un peu le
déficit des de se dire est-ce qu'on
arriverait à faire venir les gens aux
mureaux
voilà de tous les villages autour un
local partagé avec cinq autres boutiques
et des meubles en carton sur mesure
la boutique pourrait se pérenniser en
cas de succès c'est en fait une
une boutique éphémère donc on est au
sein d'un projet plus grands qui
accueille d'autres porteurs de projets
on est là normalement pour six mois et
ça permet de faire le test de vérifier
la faisabilité et si ça marche ensuite
d'avoir une vraie boutique un peu plus
grande encore pour pour avancer en
attendant de savoir si le modèle
économique est viable marc le disquaire
continuera de faire tourner ses disques
jusqu'à l'hiver un mot de sport pour
terminer maiva hamadouche validé son
billet pour tokyo la boxeuse de la team
farrugia licence et au boxing club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
s'est qualifiée pour les jeux olympiques
une place assurée après sa victoire ce
lundi contre la hongroise qatar prix bob
ce qui est lors du tournoi de
qualification olympique sts et adil bon
sur yvette en essonne l'athlète a dû
passer par la case repêchage pour ce
faire pour rappel elle est également en
lice pour être le porte drapeau de la
délégation française
réponse dans quelques semaines les jo
sont au programme du 23 juillet au 8
août à tokyo
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]